all right good evening ladies and
gentlemen
thank you for being here
if you were with us over in the dinner
uh you're probably sick of hearing me
talk at this point so you can
commiserate with my wife
my name is Patrick Whalen I'm the
president's assistant one of my
responsibilities here at the college has
been to work with doctors Scott Atlas
Jay bhattacharya and Martin coldorf to
establish and run the academy for
Science and freedom
it was founded during a time of crisis
in our country a crisis in some ways
sadly
instigated and perpetuated by what we
now recognize as a systemic malpractice
of science here in the U.S and abroad
the academy for Science and freedom
exists to educate the American people
about the free exchange of scientific
ideas and the proper relationship
between freedom and Science in The
Pursuit Of Truth
The Pursuit Of Truth indeed ought to be
at the heart
of every scientific endeavor
but the last couple of years have
demonstrated that many of our scientific
Elites and bureaucrats think the heart
of science is the manipulation of power
rather than the apprehension of Truth
the three founding fellows of the
academy for Science and freedom who it's
my pleasure to introduce this evening
work closely with Dr Arn throughout the
pandemic as you heard earlier
uh to ensure that Hillsdale College
could continue its nearly two Century
old educational work in a sane and
sensible manner free from arbitrary and
ill-informed mandates masquerading as
science
[Applause]
in the past year they have continued
that work through the academy for
Science and Freedom by addressing public
audiences around the country reaching
Millions
holding conferences with prominent
doctors and scientists challenging the
rampant censorship that has Afflicted
the public discourse
publishing ethical principles for public
health which you may have picked up on
your way in this evening
and counseling lawmakers at the state
and local level
I'll begin by introducing each one of
the fellows and then I'll ask them all
to come up at once what will happen is
each one of the our founding fellows is
going to deliver remarks
uh in succession and then we'll have a
good half an hour at the end
um where they'll be seated here and can
field your questions
so Dr Scott Atlas is the Robert Wesson
senior fellow in healthcare policy at
the Hoover institution of Stanford
University
and a fellow at Hillsdale College's
Academy for Science and freedom
Dr Atlas investigates the impact of
government and the private sector on
access quality and pricing in health
care Global Trends in healthcare
innovation
and key economic issues related to the
future of technology-based medical
advances from July to December of 2020
he served as special advisor to the
president and a member of the White
House coronavirus task force
before his appointment at Hoover
he was professor and chief of
neuroradiology at Stanford University
Medical Center for 14 years his
Publications and interviews have
appeared worldwide
Dr Atlas is the author of numerous books
most recently a plague Upon Our House my
fight at the Trump White House to stop
covid from destroying America
next we'll hear from Dr Jay bhattacharya
a professor at Stanford University
School of Medicine in the Department of
Health policy formerly in the department
of medicine and a fellow at Hillsdale
College's Academy for Science and
freedom
he also directs the center for economics
and demography of health and aging at
Stanford University
Dr bhattachary's research currently
focuses on the epidemiology of covid-19
including The lethality of covid-19
infection and the effects of lockdown
policies
he is the co-author of the Great
Barrington declaration which outlines a
return tradition to traditional Public
Health principles for managing pandemics
over his career Dr bhattacharya has
published over 150 articles in top
peer-reviewed scientific journals in
medicine economics Health policy
epidemiology statistics Law Public
Health
infectious infectious disease
epidemiology and Pediatrics among other
fields I'm not sure there are any other
fields but
Dr bhattacharya is the author of a top
selling textbook Health economics which
use which is used to teach undergraduate
and graduate students worldwide
finally we will hear from Dr Martin
koldorf a biostatistician an
epidemiologist and a professor of
medicine at Harvard University on leave
he is senior scholar at The Brownstone
Institute and a fellow at Hillsdale
College's Academy for Science and
freedom his research centers on
developing and applying new disease
surveillance methods for post-market
drug and vaccine safety surveillance
and for the early detection and
monitoring of infectious disease
outbreaks
Dr coldorf has developed new sequential
statistics statistical methods for near
real-time post-market drug and vaccine
safety surveillance where the purpose is
to use weekly or other frequent data
feeds to find potential safety problems
as soon as possible
he has also developed tree-based scan
statistic data mining methods for
post-market drug and vaccine safety
surveillance
he also is a co-author of the Great
Barrington declaration which outlines a
return to traditional Public Health
principles for managing pandemics
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
the founding fellows of the academy for
Science and freedom
[Applause]
okay thank you uh Patrick for that
introduction thank you Dr Arn for your
vision and commitment to everything in
this room that everyone in this room uh
I think feels also passionately about
and thank you all for coming
I'm going to start off by uh presenting
a talk called I called it science
Academia and the public good restoring
trust in America's institutions because
I think we're at the point where no
matter what happened uh directly about
kovid
the lingering problem now is one of
trust and a lack of trust in
institutions that are critical to the
success of this country and to any free
Society
America is in serious crisis the
government and what I call the
credentialed class
leading these essential institutions and
I mean Public Health agencies
universities
doctors scientists schools the media
have been exposed they've been exposed
as non-experts
and politicized
there is now an unprecedented denial of
fact rampant in science and in public
health leadership
as a society
during the pandemic we have broken the
social contract with our most precious
resource our children
harming them directly and failing as
role models
and fundamentally the free exchange of
ideas that is essential to finding truth
and to democracy in a free Society is
under threat now in the United States
the Cyrus pandemic what happened
well there were several claims made
early on
that were initiated by the World Health
Organization the spring early spring
2020.
and they were wrong
and anyone who had any science knowledge
after about five minutes understood that
they were calculating an infection
fatality rate with the bottom of the
fraction
being way off because they only talked
about people who were sick enough to go
see a doctor rather than the many more
people who had been infected
this was picked up by computer modelers
Public Health leaders and then given
that this is a pandemic the first ever
in the era of social media this was
Amplified over and over again
what was claimed
was that the virus had a far higher
fatality rate than the flu by several
orders of magnitude that everyone had a
significant risk to die that no one had
immunity because the virus was novel
that everyone was dangerous and spreads
the infection that asymptomatic people
are major drivers of the infection
spread that locking down will stop or
even eliminate the virus that masks will
protect everyone and stop the spread of
the infection and that immune protection
is only from getting a vaccine
all of these things were false and they
weren't just false because of learned
knowledge we knew they were all false
every one of those things by Spring of
2020.
Huxley said facts did not cease to exist
because they are ignored
we know what happened next the U.S
enacted what I call the Berks fouchy
lockdowns and that started as being
called 15 days to slow the spread
which was rational because it meant
let's see if we could slow the infection
spread so the hospitals don't get
overwhelmed so we can treat patients
including non-covet patients but that
quickly changed and it changed at the
leadership of two specific individuals
Deborah Burks who was the White House
task force coordinator officially
and who wrote all of the official
guidance to every state who visited
dozens of states with the vice president
as the face of the executive branch
policy
Anthony fauci was the second face of the
executive branch federal policy because
he had a a very significant presence in
the media he was the most visible person
and then he was named by President Biden
as chief medical advisor
as I said the first policy flattened the
curve but that rapidly became stop all
cases at all costs
and that meant lockdowns defined as
close school closures business shutdowns
limits on medical care
restrictions and mandates and
quarantines of asymptomatic healthy
people
and that result
was twofold number one it failed
there are over a million deaths
attributed to the virus under that
implemented policy
and the second part besides abject
failure was it caused massive
destruction including death
particularly
in the most vulnerable people of our
society and that includes children and
families that are poor and low income
this is the result of the United States
policy under two Administrations
and this is not political
January 20th is of course when the
administration chains hands and we
notice that curve is a straight line
really
this is not a political statement on
either Administration there's been no
change in that incremental increasing
deaths
it's important to understand lockdowners
own the outcomes they got what they
wanted their policies were implemented
the safer alternative was a alternative
was known by March 2020. it wasn't
learned it wasn't new in fact it was
standard pandemic protocol
since
15 years prior
and that was written about in the
literature in the public domain
by Johnny and Eddie's David Katz myself
in March of 2020. Martin koldorf tried
to get something published he couldn't
get something published in the United
States
so he had published CNN Espanol
and that policy was called targeted
protection which meant increase the
protection of the people who have a
significant risk to die
but don't destroy everybody else in fact
open Society particularly for medical
care schools businesses transportation
and monitor hospitals when needed
that was reiterated by several people
over the course of the spring and early
summer
seven months later
the most important document in the
pandemic was written and it was written
by two of the people on my right
Dr koldorf Dr bhattacharya and Dr
Sinatra Gupta of the United Kingdom and
that's called the Great Barrington
declaration and the most important part
of that to me
is that it gave people
Something official to say yes I agree
with that
and there's something like a million
people that have agreed with that
what's the risk and for whom
I think everybody knows this although
somehow it's not and it's never been
emphasized the risk is to people who are
older several thousand fold higher risk
of death for people are old compared to
those who are young and for perspective
in most countries the average age of
coveted death is older than the life
expectancy that doesn't diminish the
significance of dying from covet but
this is the perspective
of a rational person
two-thirds of people who died in the
United States from covet have greater
than or equal to six comorbidities
this is a disease
that when it kills people most of them
are very frail and old
the case for opening schools
was already known in spring summer 2020.
yet the United States was one of the
only countries of our peer Nations that
closed schools for fall 2020.
the rationale I presented at the White
House in an event because I thought okay
what am I going to do I got there
August 1st basically what's the most
important thing open the schools
because healthy children do not have a
high risk from the virus because the
harms of closing in-person schools are
enormous
and there is nothing in my view more
important to any civilized society than
educating its children
we also knew from the spring 2020
closures that online learning was a
failure it was recognized throughout the
world and it had not it was not due to
lack of broadband that is a complete
fallacy Netherlands has the highest
penetration of broadband in the world
and they had a massive drop in learning
the losses were Beyond learning everyone
here you don't have to be a parent to
understand that we need that you
socialize in school you need you learn
conflict resolution physical activity in
people who are poor it's the most
nutritious meal of the day for their
child that's word problems with hearing
and visual impairment are discovered in
school you don't get that on a computer
and all of these losses are far greater
for minorities and the poor for a
society that's focused and says it's
focused over and over again on helping
poor people and low-income families it
was a gross failure
America closes schools and what happened
well first we see that that square box
is compared to the previous year
Hospital medical visits to doctors
dropped every month for physical illness
that's because coveted care was
non-coveted care was shut down and
people were so afraid they weren't
seeking medical care but this is
psychiatric illness in teenagers
exploded during the lockdowns every
month this is self-harm visits double to
Triple kids putting cigarettes out on
their skin because they were isolated
from the lockdowns this is psychiatric
illness in college age students
anxiety depression exploding during the
lockdowns this is drug abuse in
teenagers this is not due to the virus
this is due to the man-made decision of
locking down
lockdowns inflicted worldwide harms
particularly to children
not to mention the one and a half
billion children worldwide they were
shot out of Education more than a
hundred million more children underrun
sexual abuse gentle mutilation childhood
pregnancies that's the reality
that the other side never talks about
that chart is from the journal the
magazine Economist which shows an
explosion in the percentage of children
that cannot read or understand a simple
phrase
in the world
Mandela said there can be no Keener
revelation of a society's Soul than the
way in which it treats its children
America failed
the lockdowns were a failure this is the
data this is not an opinion
this is bjornskov March 2021 24 European
countries evaluated there was no
decrease
in in death with lockdowns that's the
reason the lockdowns were done because
we were going to quote save people's
lives
this is a Stanford study Ben David and
colleagues that did not find that
stricter lockdowns
prevented the growth of cases the spread
of cases was not stopped
this is National Bureau economic
research Rand Institute June 2021
looking at 43 countries and the United
States and they found that when the
lockdowns were employed the deaths
increased
which of course makes sense when the
lockdowns of men staying inside in
proximity to people or while they were
closing the beaches
only from January 22.
Johns Hopkins
they looked at all the studies in the in
the in the world and their bottom line
conclusion is lockdown policies were
ill-founded and shouldn't be rejected as
a pandemic policy instrument there was
not a dramatic decrease in mortality and
they they were associated with
significant harms we knew this this was
standard pandemic management 15 years
before this pandemic
this is a latest study April 2022
kerpen and others including University
of Chicago Economist Casey Mulligan
analyzed 50 states and Quantified how
they did with pandemic Management in
three ways death
harms to the economy and harms to
education
this is the top set of states
you'll notice it in the top five
are two of the states that didn't lock
down
South Dakota and Florida
this is the worst states performance
Illinois California New York New Jersey
if you're wondering Michigan ranked 40th
Feynman said it does not matter who you
are or how smart you are or what title
you have or how many of you there are
and certainly not how many papers your
site is published if your prediction is
wrong your hypothesis is wrong period
That's science
lockdowns hurt low-income families yet
spared the affluent one of the great
sins of the lockdowners
this is the significant drop in
employment you'll notice that the
lowered and sustained drop is in the
low-income jobs
this is the significant drop in
educational level the lower
educational level is the low-income
families
this is the job losses that persist that
are separated on the base of wage
low-income job losses
are persistently much lower than higher
income
this was a massive destruction
at the expense of the middle class and
the lower class
for the benefit of the affluent
and that's why it's called a luxury of
the rich lockdowns are a luxury of the
rich that's a phrase borrowed from
Serena I mean from Sinatra
okay lockdown's economic arms equal
lives lost this was known for decades
yet the economists were silent I was
asked to co-author this paper in the
spring of 2020 by an economist at
University of Chicago but none of my
colleagues
were working on this or talking about it
and so we did and we said that by Spring
of 2020
the number of Life years lost was double
from the lockdowns than it was from the
virus
that went unnoticed
lockdowns directly killed people why
Well Medical Care was shut down half of
650 000 U.S chemo patients
didn't seek their chemo they have cancer
on chemo they were afraid to go and they
were made to afraid made to be afraid
stroke heart attack these half the
people didn't call an ambulance organ
transplants 85 percent decrease from the
previous year
I won't go through all this data but
suffice it to say that over the next 20
years it's estimated that 1.2 million
Americans will die from the unemployment
and economic downturn along
and most of those are low-income people
I want to talk about vaccines but only
in this context to me coveted vaccines
in children are a case study
in defining a virtuous Society
coveted vaccines in the United Kingdom
the margin of benefit is too small
to support advice on a universal program
of vaccination of healthy 12 to 15 year
old children
because remember the risks to children
that are healthy is an infinitesimally
small from the disease
coveted vaccines in Finland
participation in vaccination is
voluntary people under 16 who are not at
a risk group
will not be vaccinated
that's Finland
Norway for children who are offered the
vaccine
under 16 that's their age of consent
parents must consent to vaccination must
consent
and in the case of joint parental
responsibility both parents must consent
and again vaccination is voluntary
that's Norway
Denmark I'm not going to read the Danish
here
but they published something that said
from July 1 onward it will no longer be
possible for children and young people
under the age of 18 to get the first jab
and from September 1 will no longer be
possible to get the second
that's Dana shelf Authority
how did the American Media react to that
they immediately published a fact check
they called it Denmark did not ban
coveted vaccines for children and if you
read that small writing there
they said well because they said
children at high risk can still get the
vaccine
so they didn't ban that's false on
social media these people are right-wing
lunatics who are saying that
I added that they didn't say that
what about the U.S
Eric Rubin the elder-in-chief of the New
England Journal said but we're never
going to learn about how safe the
vaccine is unless we start giving it
that's just the way it goes
that's an FDA advisory meeting on
vaccine approval specifically in
children
it's even worse
this is a clinical trial going on from
the NIH and in red at the bottom not
only are they doing the vaccine trials
on healthy children who again have no
significant risks from coven
healthy children
they're saying they're going to do the
vaccines on children under six months of
age
this is the paper that came out of that
work so far
on children 5 to 11 and you'll notice
you can't read it probably but at the
bottom are some of our favorite academic
research medical centers Duke University
Stanford University
to me this is a massive break of medical
ethics
to use an experimental drug on young
children who are healthy who have no
significant risk from the illness you're
giving them the vaccine for
to me U.S Public Health ethics have
disappeared this was a statement if a
school is implementing a testing
strategy testing should be offered on a
voluntary basis it is unethical and
illegal to test someone who does not
want to be tested including students
whose parents do not want them to be
tested that's not even about vaccines
that's just forced testing that was said
by the CDC posted by the CDC in October
of 2020. not only have the ethics
disappeared that document has
disappeared I happen to have it
that's removed from the internet
why did the public believe lockdowners
well we are of a culture of trust we
trust the credentials
there was a lot of fear in society
understandable fear of covet but also
fear of those who didn't believe or
agree of speaking out I cancel culture
which I'm going to talk about
and then of course media and politics in
the United States
really are vicious and there's been a
real demonization of anyone who speaks
otherwise
the public believe two key lies number
one if you're against lockdowns you're
choosing the economy over lives that was
known to be a lie
as I Illustrated and also if you're
against lockdowns you're somehow for
allowing the infection to spread without
mitigation the so-called herd immunity
strategy which you've heard a lot about
and of course no one here ever said
anything like that that was never said
never advised to the president I never
even heard anyone discuss that in the
White House
that's called propaganda because that
was perpetrated onto the public the
media Amplified that this is a meeting
that we had with Sinatra Gupta
October 5 2020 with HHS secretary Alex
azer
we talked about a lot of things we never
talked about herd immunity it was never
even mentioned we have the transcript of
the meeting
yet the hill who interviewed us
claimed Trump Health officials meet with
doctors pushing herd immunity
and that sentence there says that this
strategy is gaining momentum to let the
infection spread without mitigation
with Scott Atlas and others
that's a complete lie we saw that piece
we two of us called the author of that
piece and shamefully they wouldn't
retract it we never talked about that
America's media is unique it's uniquely
poisonous
this is all covered stories and
English-speaking media Quantified as
negative or positive the non-us media 54
negative
U.S media 91 negative
in 2020 the U.S media stories of
increasing cases outnumbered the stories
of decreasing cases by a factor of over
five even when the cases were declining
this was known in fact it wasn't enough
that they were lying they also censored
information these are two different
articles quantifying how YouTube is
proudly saying
that they're censoring information
we were all censored in various ways and
many others were I'm pointing out my own
experience because uh I think it it
makes a certain point September 11th
YouTube pulled down an interview I did
on covid but the interview was up for
four months
as soon as I got to Washington
they pulled it down and said it's
misinformation it wasn't misinformation
before I was standing next to president
Trump on the podium
October 18th Twitter deleted my post as
advisor to the president on covid
talking about the data quoting the data
on masks
I would think that the American people
would want to hear
what the advisor to the president was
saying
about the biggest Health Care crisis in
a hundred years but no it wasn't allowed
and even later
I had left in November Jay and I and
Martin went down to work with Governor
DeSantis in a press conference
YouTube filmed it and they pulled it
down and said it's misinformation
by November 2020 Facebook had taken down
seven million posts on the on the
pandemic and they bragged about it in
the Washington Post
some people in the media understood this
is the Wall Street Journal editorial
board saying the public can be forgiven
for wondering if Dr Alice's appointment
as a White House coronavirus advisor
last month has made him a political
Target
this is the Federalist
saying his opinions have become of
Greater interest due to his appointment
in August as a presidential advisor
that fact alone
ought to make it vital that the public
hears his opinions
it's not just the media in Galileo's
time it was said the real problem is
vested academic interests
scientific journals block the scientific
process
even if people are dying this is the
Lancet February 2020 you may remember
this paper a bunch of famous virologists
got together and submitted a letter with
no data saying We Stand Together to
strongly condemn conspiracy theories
suggesting that kovid does not have a
natural origin this is February 2020.
it's not even known today frankly it
could not have been known that it was a
natural virus
in 2020 February
the universities are censoring people
because they perceive them as political
opponents how do I know that because I'm
talking about Stanford University where
I work there were three scientists there
Johnny and Edie's me and Jay
bhattacharya we all said the exact same
thing about who's at risk the risk to
Children immunity masks not being
effective schools should open lockdowns
were wrong and focused protection was
the way to go we said the exact same
thing
yet Stanford University faculty members
in the medical school got together and
wrote and posted a letter
condemning me personally
and trying to sort of cancel me
this is a list of almost 100 people
just to flash it up there to show the
reality of what was going on here
that kind of shame that that kind of
behavior is shameful
when you have somebody criticized and
delegitimized because they have the
audacity to try to help the country
under a president that you personally
despise that's shameful conduct harmful
to the National interest and a gross
failure as a role model to our youth
how do I know it's political this is the
voting of Stanford's zip code 95 Joe
Biden 3 percent Trump when California
was two to one Biden the Trump
this also was noticed and this was
written about
that cancel culture had come to Madison
and it was called mob rule
public health is now politicized not
sure you can read that but this is the
public support by party of opening K-12
schools
and there's a massive difference between
Republicans and Democrats that should
never happen
there should not be political ingredient
in the leadership of Public Health or in
the acceptance of Public Health Science
itself trust in science has been
politicized it was always about equal to
parties and then look what happened
massive distrust by the Republicans
there's something wrong
can we restore a trust yes there are
many specific things to do we don't have
time to go through them but first and
foremost we have to restate and then
insist on the ethical principles that
were broken in public health and we just
did that in the academy for Science and
freedom we have to demand the
accountability including admission of
errors in public forums
anyone who's married knows how good it
is to say you're wrong when you're wrong
and there are many other things to do
including uh require transparency and I
think Martin and jail talk about that I
just want to point out but the most
essential ingredient of all to stop what
is going on
is leaders must rise up
this is a leader Martin koldorf stood up
when that letter was written
it said I would be delighted to debate
this with any of the 98 signatories in
the Stanford newspaper zero took him up
on that challenge
thank you
[Applause]
another way is to bring in more experts
and I brought in Jay and Martin
Joe ladapo Cody Meisner
to see the president in the Oval Office
and this is why this is where we are in
August of 2020 why because the president
United States needs to have people who
are doing the research to answer his
questions
this was blocked internally
and I went crazy and got it done uh much
of the dismay of people who are trying
to block it
we also need to start new institutions
and that's what this is about this is
the academy for Science and freedom this
is Dr art introducing us three at the
Kirby Center in Washington I think this
there is nothing more important if we
are a society that doesn't believe in
facts anymore I don't even know where to
go from there we need to fix science
it's broken
this is the document that we just posted
on the website I encourage all you to
take the handout or to look at it on the
website where we co-authored with
several other leaders uh all over the
country in fact some in the outside the
U.S on restating what shouldn't even
need to be restated about the ethical
principles of Public Health
and last comment here
it took the Catholic Church
359 years to admit that Galileo was
right and the Earth moved
I'm not so sure I have the confidence
that we're going to beat 359 years here
lastly Winston Churchill
Dr Arn's favorite said truth is
incontrovertible Panic May resent it
ignorance made the ride at malice made
distorted but there it is thank you very
much
[Applause]
not sure I'm going to follow that but
I'll uh it's been an absolute honor and
inspirational lifetime to be able to
work with uh with uh Dr Atlas and Dr
cooldorf through the pandemic I want to
focus my remarks on a a narrower topic
because this is the the Academy of
Science and freedom and I wanna I wanna
understand how the federal science
bureaucracy corrupted science
and at the end after I finish my story
I'll I'll offer one suggestion for how
to how to start to fix it but I'm hoping
in the Q a we can have a more robust
discussion about this
uh okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna go like
three three points I want to make
um first that the the lockdowns were an
absolutely extraordinary measure
that were unprecedented in human history
and in fact what I'm going to show you
is that they were not part of the
standard pandemic plans that we had in
place at the start of the pandemic
uh the second point I want to make is
that the way that the lockdowns were
instituted
the the key thing was the creation of a
illusion of scientific consensus
that actually did not exist even when
they were implemented and never
throughout the pandemic and this
illusion was created by federal
bureaucrats working to to essentially
fool the American people into thinking
that they were following the
science
laughs
um and uh last I'll talk very briefly
about how we might be able to fix this
because I do think that one of the the
great opportunities to come out of the
pandemic is the sense that we are in
crisis as a society uh that that a way
that science can be used to rule the
lives of people is is not right and
we can stand up to that and transform it
to reform it you know in a way that
science can have its proper place in
society that in fact that's what the
Academy Science and freedom is all about
okay uh first pandemic plans
uh do you know this person
it's really unjust that most people in
the room don't know this person this
this person is the man that rid the
world of smallpox if you've ever not
worried about smallpox it's thanks to
this man he's probably the most
important epidemiologist of the 20th
century his name is Donald Henderson
um he died in 2016. there's a his
obituary in the New York Times
um
he uh the reason I put put this picture
of this man up is that if he had been
alive six years later or I guess four
years later in 2020 we probably would
not have had the lockdown because he
would have stopped he would he would
have stood up against it how do I know
this
in uh 2006 he wrote a paper uh called
with the very horrible title disease
mitigation measures in the in control of
pandemic influenza I can see you falling
asleep already but this is super
exciting and interesting
um
let me let me show you let me show you
just some some Choice quotes I'm going
to read it because it's really worth
hearing his words
um as experience shows for quarantines
there is no basis for recommending
quarantines either for groups or
individuals this is in case of pandemic
influenza including
it influenz us that we've experienced
during our lifetime the problems in
implementing such measures are
formidable and secondary effects of
absenteeism and Community disruption as
well as possible adverse consequences
such as loss of public trust in
government and stigmatization of
quarantine groups and people are likely
to be considerable
he was right wasn't he that's 2006.
um
uh okay a communication strategy and
plan
open and frequent Communications to the
public are essential that usually means
not lying to the public right
um this involves regular press
conferences face times and
proximity of information through Civic
leaders churches schools and businesses
an important message is to request that
all uh who are ill remain isolated
stay at home if you're sick
or in the hospital but to encourage
others to continue to come to work so
that essential Services can be sustained
any word about healthy people staying at
home
and last one last this this whole paper
is worth reading but this is the best
part an overriding principle
experience has shown the communities
faced with epidemics or other Adverse
Events respond best and with the least
anxiety when the normal social function
of community or at least is least
disrupted strong political and public
health leadership to provide reassurance
and ensure that needed medical services
are provided are critical elements if
either seem to be less than optional a
manageable epidemic could move toward
catastrophe
a society that functions
calmly in the face of danger is the best
way to manage a pandemic is what he said
he would have stood up for this and I
think I I think if he lived for four
years longer we would not have had a
lockdown the man that stopped the the
that eradicated smallpox from the face
of the Earth
okay what did we get instead
um
so uh you don't recognize the man on the
left the man on the left is Cliff Lane
he was Tony fauci's Deputy I put him up
because he he played a really Central
role in the lockdown the option of
lockdown and of course everyone
recognized that man in the middle over
there
um Tony fauci the head of the National
Institute of algae infectious disease
um in February of 2020
the World Health Organization had a
delegation sent to China to try to
understand what happened in China
and how they controlled the pandemic how
they stopped the disease from spreading
they sent two people one uh was at
Stanford trained epidemiologist named
Maria kirchhoff that's on she's on top
and then on the bottom is Cliff Lane
Cliff Lane is Tony is Tony fauci's
deputy
uh that it's there was a whole series of
of freedom information act requests that
that were required to get this
information to you also so you could see
this
um on the flight home from China they
wrote a report
um this report is called a report of the
World Health Organization China uh joint
mission on the coronavirus disease
so they they were they were flying home
rapidly typing this report up
um in February 26 2020 February 2020.
about three or four weeks before the
lockdown is implemented in the United
States
uh
let me read this to you prepare here
this is this is the advice that they
gave remember we just listened to Don
Henderson's advice
um prepare to immediately activate the
highest level emergency response
mechanisms to trigger the all of
government and all of society approach
that is essential for early containment
of covet 19. they came back
saying that not just American society
Maria kirkov worked for the World Health
Organization but all of world society
should lock down
there's a email that Cliff Lane sent to
the National Institute of allergy
infected disease as soon as he came back
home
and here's what he wrote to Tony fauci
he wrote China has demonstrated this
infection it became controlled albeit at
Great cost
that is the bottom line from my
perspective the global Community needs
to decide the way forward that room
needs more than this group
uh I'm not sure that President Trump
ever saw this email in fact I'm pretty
sure he probably didn't see this email
um what what Cliff Lane was suggesting
is that China what China did locking
down its uh its one of its largest
cities Wuhan had worked
we'd gotten rid of the disease they've
gotten rid of the disease and all we had
to do is follow their example
and we also could get rid of the disease
uh okay I'm not going to belabor this
because Scott did a fantastic job
telling you about the collateral harms
of lockdown
um the the effects of this were entirely
predictable Don Henderson before he died
predicted it and I'll just I just picked
some some a few pictures should show you
uh in uh March of 2020 India also locked
down actually partly on the advice of
the World Health Organization and partly
because they were following Tony fauci
who had an enormous impact not just on
American public policy and public health
but worldwide
I spoke to Indian epidemiologists who
would often cite him
um and what happened was on that first
day when they locked down nearly a half
a billion people migrant workers who
work hand to mouth in cities around
India
were told they had to walk back to their
get back somehow to their home Villages
sometimes a thousand miles away
now working hand-to-mouth means I buy a
coconut
I then sell the coconut to some rich
Mumbai I.T worker then with that money I
buy more coconuts and I feed my family
and those more coconuts I sell the next
day
when India locked down the life savings
of a half billion migrant workers
disappeared overnight
and on the March back home which some
academics have called it the new Trail
of Tears a thousand poor migrant workers
died overnight
uh this was from the U.N in uh 2020. the
virus linked hunger tied to ten thousand
child deaths each month why did hunger
happen well we we globalized our world
economy didn't we over the last 30s it
was an enormous success a billion people
lifted out of poverty
poor countries around the world
reorganize their economies to fit into
the global economy and overnight we
broke it
and hundreds of millions of people 100
million people were thrown into poverty
and tens of millions of people
faced severe hunger and
ten thousand child deaths each month uh
in May of 2021 this is from the BBC uh
the the U.N estimated that
just in that year alone 230
000 children had died from Hunger in
just in South Asia
I'm focusing on India because I'm of
Indian extraction I could do this for
Africa I could do this for every poor
country on Earth every poor person on
Earth was harmed materially sometimes to
death
as a consequence of the decisions that
Western countries took to lock down
uh this is Ghana uh these These are kids
from Ghana there are 15 million children
in Ghana
and uh actually is this for God no this
is Uganda yeah sorry this I I have one
from Ghana too which is pretty bad but
this is this one's this one's even worse
Uganda there's 15 million kids in Uganda
and four and a half million for two
years they were out of school
not remote School
very few of them had access to the
internet to have remote School just out
of school
four and a half million of those kids
never showed up after the schools
reopened
this is a catastrophe for the world's
poor
it's also a catastrophe for for American
Kids this is from The New York Times
just uh just yesterday
I love the phrasing the pandemic erased
two decades of progress in math and
reading because the scores
who's already not so good before how to
think about the pandemic but it wasn't
the pandemic that did this and it was
poor families that faced the worst of it
and it's poor families in blue States
largely that closed the schools that
caused that where this this pandemic
learning loss has happened
um the consequences of this we're going
to be paying for for a very long time
our kids are going to be paying for
because it's it's a fact that if you
interrupt a child's education for even a
short time they pay the harms of that
over their entire life they lead poorer
less healthy shorter lives and they're
in fact an estimate during the pandemic
that just the spring lockdowns alone
robbed our children of five and a half
million life years
over the next decades
okay uh the Great Barrington declaration
I I gotta say I got to tell you
something
um
I love this I love this probably my
proudest moment is is writing and
signing this great branch of Declaration
but I'll tell you and you'll see this
immediately as soon as I show it to you
there's not one original thought in it
because and this is how you apparently
how you get how you uh how you how you
say something important you just steal
shamelessly from the very best people
um
uh the so the great financial decoration
uh we signed it in 20 October 4th 2020
there's a networked in the middle and
there's Martin cooldorf I've been told
this looks like a rock star video kind
of thing uh I I I don't know
uh
maybe Martin does um the idea is so
simple you have this age gradient
old people are at high risk from the
disease young people are are much lower
almost vanishingly low risk whereas
young people especially everyone's
harmed by lockdown but especially young
people interrupting their lives is
harmful what should you do
well uh you care about care taking care
of people who are a threat from illness
so you care for the old you focus
protection on the old you make sure that
people have the resources they need so
that they don't for instance organize
campaigns to have deliveries when
there's High case rates uh to older
people living next door make available
for for older people living in
multi-generational homes make available
hotel rooms we made hotel rooms
available for young homeless people why
not make it available for older people
so that if you know uh grandson Johnny
comes home says or calls and says
Grandma I think I was exposed to the
virus she calls up public health and
says can I have a place to stay for a
couple of days
right very simple kinds of ideas local
public health fully had it in their
capacity to be creative and think of
ways to protect older people other
societies did this
for the rest of society especially for
children
let's just follow the Don Henderson plan
don't disrupt their lives
Don't Panic people
allow our children to go to school
um I told you we stole the ideas
simplest plan in the world right makes
complete sense
um
we wrote this on October 4th 2020
here's the focus protection better
protection deal
um we wrote this in October before 2020.
where uh the emphasis is on protecting
the old and then opening Society for the
Young
um
the um plan was followed by Sweden I I
leave this I show this here just to give
you a sense of what perfect Focus
protection can look like
what Sweden did when the vaccines came
was that they they vaccinated all of
their old population in fact they were
so strict about it that when a 40 year
old Swedish Public Health official
sneakily vaccinated himself uh they
fired him
they made sure that all of the doses now
Sweden like the rest of Europe actually
was relatively slow in the early days of
the vaccination campaign every dose in
Sweden went to an older person
and so it's on the top you see cases you
see this big hump you have these two
humps looks like a camel
in Winter there was a big wave of cases
in Sweden and then then again in the
spring there was a big wave of cases in
Sweden
on the bottom you see deaths the first
wave when the the winter wave there was
no vaccine you see all a huge number of
deaths
by vaccinating the old they'd they
basically had decoupled cases and deaths
that second wave do you see a second
hump at the bottom
no deaths because they had protected the
old
that is what the end point of this
pandemic is
cases forever but not producing deaths
because we protected people
um and by the way your immunity if
you've any who in the room has had
coveted and recovered
you're pretty well protected as budget
is about as well as you can be
um
doesn't mean you're not going to get it
again just means that you're you're when
you get it it's likely to be less severe
than the first time
uh no promises this is science right um
four four days after we wrote The Great
Barrington declaration
um the uh the head of the National
Institute of Health a man named Francis
Collins
wrote an email
I've long admired the man I have to say
it pains me to talk about this about him
doing this actually honestly it does I I
and and this is this is I don't mean
this uh in any false way I mean I I
admired his career forever
um so but four days after we wrote The
Great branch of necklace on October 8th
a million people almost a million people
had signed it tens of thousands of
epidemiologists and doctors had signed
it uh a Nobel Prize winner at Stanford
signed it uh Scott were you allowed to
sign it you must have signed it
Scott didn't sign it
he was a little he's in the white house
okay
but see
you can tell the
also had these same ideas it's not like
any of this was what was particularly
original right
um the point is
there was an enormous community of
scientists who understood that the
lockdowns were in a huge mistake
four days after we wrote The Great
Barrington declaration after this huge
outpouring let me read the email to you
um it's a little painful so you know uh
hi Tony and Cliff Tony is Tony fauci
Cliff is Cliff Lane the man who went on
that junket to China I showed you
earlier hi Tony and Cliff uh cgb
declaration.org that's that's my website
I love that's the website um The
Proposal uh from the three Fringe
epidemiologists that's that's me wait
that's me Martin kuldorf and sunetto
Gupta
Stanford
he was Harvard I think a friend's school
if I ever heard of one and then and
symmetric grouped at Oxford University
um uh this proposal for three French
opening knowledge who met with a
secretary that's the picture that that
uh that Scott showed you uh secretary
Azar seems to be getting a lot of
attention
this is four days by the way after we
wrote this and even a co-signia from a
Nobel Prize winner Mike Levitt at
Stanford that's my friend
he he's a Nobel Prize winner signed it
it's Fringe epidemiology right there
needs to be a quick and devastating
published takedown of the premises I
don't see anything like that online yet
is it underway
I have
a business card this is not the one this
is my official one I have an unofficial
one printed up with fringe
epidemiologists which is now my official
title
then we got stories like this Scott
showed you one from the hill uh Trump
wants to try for herd immunity without a
vaccine it could kill Millions we'd
already killed millions in people
starving in four parts of the world
uh we didn't mention herd immunity I
started getting calls from reporters and
I was puzzled they asked me Jay they'd
say Dr bhattacharya they'd be nice to me
uh Dr rashai why do you want to let the
virus rip
I was really I was honestly puzzled
because the words let it rip does not
appear in the Great Barrington
declaration
I actually never thought about letting
the virus syrup I mean gosh I mean that
that seems like a really you know I I
thought we'd argued for Focus protection
um instead we got this
a coordinated propaganda campaign to
destroy the reputations of anybody that
signed it
coordinated by the government by the
American federal government
uh Tony fauci
uh
responded to Francis Collins uh with a
email too busy with other things to
worry about this they are too busy they
meaning the White House
is too busy to worry about this this
story that the Washington Post story
that I just showed you Francis Collins
quoted calling calling us accusing us of
Wanaka irresponsibly infect the entire
American population they the White House
is too busy with what the election this
is October 2020.
um to worry about this what you said was
entirely correct Tony fauci
robber stamped French epidemiology
uh Francis Collins response my quotes
are accurate I but I will not be
appreciated by the White House
um and he doubled down when he was when
he finally resigned as head of the NIH
he went on Fox news and it was asked
about this he said he stood by the stood
by it a full year later
okay uh last last slide about reform how
do we fix things I'm just I'm just gonna
give one idea one idea there's many more
that's going to be needed but I wanted
to emphasize this idea because I like it
sort of the because it's so clean and
easy to understand
um
we need a a wall a real wall
between science and the science funders
uh
what is it is it okay if if a f if uh if
if you have a pharmaceutical company
executive make decisions about whether
to approve or not approve drugs by the
FDA
seems like there'd be conflict interest
there right
when you have powerful science funders
like Francis Collins like Tony fauci who
say uh you know I really think that if
you if a lockdown is the right way to go
now they control 40 billion dollars of
money 40
now it's not just that funds
the work of nearly every prominent
epidemiologist immunologist and
virologist in the country
it's not just money they control so I
teach at Stanford University in order to
get tenure at this at the school of
medicine at Stanford University it's
almost a requirement that you get NIH
funding
it's it's a sort of Mark of you've
you've succeeded because you've
convinced the NIH to to give you money
it's how you attain status within
science
when a scientific funder
prominent scientific functor like Tony
fauci says it uh that lockdowns are the
only way everyone else who disagrees
with him is our what does he say he said
uh if you disagree with him you're not
simply disagreeing with a man you are
disagreeing with science
um I don't know if you speak French I I
thought of Louis XIV uh lacion Seymour
that Louis said no he said he had some
other approach it was something very
close to that right
um
it's um it's you do it at risk to your
own
success as a scientist
so what needs to happen is a bright wall
just like there's a bright wall between
pharmaceutical company Executives and
the FDA that's at least they're supposed
to be one
okay we can have Bright Walls all over
the place
um there's but this one is a new one
that I hadn't thought of before the
pandemic there needs to be bright wall
between scientific funders making
decisions about who to fund and their
participation in health policy because
that is a deep conflict of interest that
silence as scientists creates an
illusion of consensus that doesn't exist
fools the American people fools the
world populations and doing things that
are very very dangerous
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's wonderful to be here at Hillsdale
College such a
beautiful place with wonderful people so
thank you from from my part of my heart
for inviting us here
Kobe was is not the first pandemic we've
had uh pandemics for
uh for thousands of years
so ever since I was a teenager I've been
very interested in history so what can
we learn about infectious diseases from
history
uh well in 430 BC we have a plague of
Athen it also affected other places
and
figured ditus who survives this plague
he wrote The Following
those who have had those who had
recovered from the disease
had now no fear for themselves
for the same man was never attacked
twice never at least fatally
so the Greek they knew that if you had
an infection then you had immunity
and you were not at high risk again
uh so we knew that two and a half
thousand years ago so now we're going to
go forward in time a little bit
uh
uh so this was part of a letter written
they call it the memorandum living in in
the landsat which uh was supposed to be
one of the prestigious uh medical
journals in the world uh it says there
is no evidence for lasting protective
immunity to a source code 2 following
natural infection
um this was signed by Rochelle valensky
and about 40 other people and later by
hundreds of others who did it afterwards
uh the reason I put Rochelle valenski is
here a few months after these words she
was appointed the director of CDC
so it's pretty amazing how our knowledge
about infections can change over two and
a half thousand years
it's even more amazing that for from
430 BC to 2019 we knew one thing and
then in the last two years we suddenly
forgotten about all of that
so this is only one example of how we
have large tasks with science and the
truth and so on
so in October to 20 when Scott was
censored one of several times
my comment on Twitter was that
we have now come to the End of the Age
of Enlightenment of scientific
enlightenment
I think it was 400 years ago when
tikobara Johannes Kepler Galileo
Descartes they sort of put down the
foundation of modern science
and with very open inquisitive mind with
a good d-based discussions but now if we
can't have these discourse in science
then we can't have enlightenment
I will have both discourse and
Enlightenment if you don't have this
course there is no enlightenment
that's a pretty stunning and scary
thought I think that we're heading into
such a Direction
so
uh
one way would be to replace Rochelle
valensky with Scott or Jay
and whoever doesn't replace social
replace uh Anthony I guess but there is
actually a more structural problems here
it's not just the issue of personalities
that the wrong person happened to get
into the wrong position because
we should have a system that's robust
enough to deal with that because we can
never always appoint appoint the best
person to the right job
and that comes into
how the
academic and the scientific Community
operates
and that's what is now the task for the
Academy of Science and freedom
to
revise and restructure how science
operates
and the public health and this pandemic
has sort of put this to Swiss that is
obvious that yes the problems to be
obvious but these are things that has
been sort of simmering for for a long
time in the scientific community
and
academic peer review comes to the heart
of this and academic peer reviews sort
of have in three components to it one is
reviews when grants are evaluated who
should get research funding
reviews when
papers are published who should publish
and promotions
in in academics we sort of call it get
grants or get lost and publish or perish
so all scientists know this that this is
also the key to have to be able to have
a a career in science and do some good
work
um now if you look here
uh there's sort of a cartel system
you have Journal editors and reviewers
of Articles Grant review committees
promotional writers they tend to be do
you see some similarities between these
three groups
so and it's not that it's like one
cartel for all of science it's like you
have one cartel for each subfield of
science
so there's like hundreds of these
cartels
and some of them actually kind of nice
because they are encouraging discussions
and so on but there are many many where
there's sort of a viciousness and if you
don't follow the leaders
then you're out you're never going to be
funded and there's sort of this click
that you can't really upset them
so I think what's key to reforming how
the scientific Community operates is the
decentralization
so instead of one a man Dr Anthony
faucier who sits on the biggest pile of
infections with these money in the world
you can have multiple of these and if
faucially the the purple group there in
the back that's kind of okay they're
going to mess up but at least we have
uh seven and other ones that are
functioning and then science will
function
so this kind of decentralization I think
is is critical for the future
of Science and the future of the
Enlightenment
and we can sort of illustrate that
actually during this pandemic because as
we were sort of trying to find important
information about what was going on with
kovitch
the the important studies of that sort
of first gave us information about
different things
did not come typically from the two big
powerhouses in science the United States
of America and the United Kingdom of
Great Britain and Northern Ireland
it came from the periphery of science so
like Rich small rich countries
that have good science but they're
Smalls and they don't belong they have
this belong to the same publication
journals so they have sort of where the
cartel has some power over them but on
the funding there's less because they
have their own national funding agencies
so they are not as effective of this
cartel system they are to some extent
but not as much as scientists in the U.S
than UK and other countries so for
example about schools the best studies
came from Sweden and Finland should be
open or not
do children transmit coordinates well
the best study came from Iceland not the
what you think of as the scientific
Powerhouse of the world but they they
did an excellent study on that
zero prevalence how many people have
antibodies and how did that vary by age
group and other things the best study
came from Spain
Mass there's only been two randomized
trials on mask and the first one was
from Denmark didn't show any effect but
it was a very well designed study
uh National immunity the best early
study came from Israel it showed that
immunity from natural immunity from
having recovered was better than
vaccine-induced immunity
the vaccine efficacy how how fast does
the protection went it protects quite
fast for infection it lasts longer for
serious disease the best data come from
Qatar and from Sweden vaccine safety
from Israel and Denmark so it came from
these sort of smaller peripheral
countries and I think that's because
they are not asked right into this
scientific cartel system as as we are in
the United States and they are in the
United Kingdom
so what do we do this specifically and
these are some suggestions and that we
want to work with uh in the academy and
these are not sort of the finished plan
or anything like that but there's really
no need to have competitive scientific
journals where as a scientist you have
to publish in the lands that or in
science
at one point these journals were very
important because they had to be sent to
the libraries in the paper copy so that
people could read them but we don't
really need that service anymore so now
the only thing they do is sort of to be
a hurdle for who gets to be the
prominent scientist who later will get
funding and promotions so it's sort of a
purpose for the cartel system but it
doesn't really serve much else purpose
for the scientific community so we can
instead ask the universities and
research institutes having the agents
and you just publish it wherever you
happen to work
with uh and if you're professor at
Stanford I think why stop them from
publishing I mean if if they're not good
scientists they shouldn't be working at
Stanford so just let them publish and
then we can open peer review so that
it's published together with you see
what
what the reviewers actually think now
it's it's a secret Anonymous peer review
and it's never shown what they think
about it so is that we should say well
Jay wrote a paper and the one review you
think this is the greatest paper ever
and other things that know this
completely fatal flaws or whatever but
you have these reviews that comes with
it
uh I think that second uh Karma probably
not not very likely unless he's some
Professor from Harvard like Valencia or
something but but I don't know uh
it will be much rapid Publications
um open access for anybody can read it
instead of having a a financial toll on
reading it and then if I write something
and I say oh yeah that comment was
actually good I should change it then I
can change the paper
I just made it Uber software uh so those
are some of the ideas sort of improve
the whole publication communication
system and research funding we need as I
said multiple independent funding
agencies
I think also now we sort of give grants
to somebody can come up with some ideas
of what to do
but why not instead reward people who
did past research good really action
movies in the past because they were
probably good research next time also
and that gives them more freedom to
actually pursue what they want because
what happens to me sometimes I really
want to do this thing
but I don't have any funding but I do it
anyhow but then I do these other two
things because that's my funding so I
have to do those two things that are
less important just so I can also do the
important one
so I think you can do get much better
and more rapid research if you had that
system instead
and then when it comes to Young
researchers instead of having grants
committers do it you can get a little
universities sort of Select that now the
university is first hire them and then
they have to write a grant for NIH to
get funded and if they don't they get
fired eventually like it had to go a few
years and otherwise they're not but why
don't you just sort of combine that it
will be more efficient so usually has
some ideas for it and for promotion I
think qualitative
evaluations rather than quantitative but
if you do quantity we need better
research metrics for doing those things
and basically you know ignore what
Journal it is it should be the actual
research that's important not what
generally it happened to have been
published in
so those are some of the ideas that we
have for reforming the the
scientific community that we want to
work with in the academy we also want to
work with other things like
scientific communication to the public
and so on
so a couple of weeks ago I wrote another
tweet I don't know if this is accurate
or not so just putting it out there so
you can you're welcome to argue with me
here but during the 16th century
Reformation many lay people understood
the Bible better than most priests
during the 21st century pandemic many
lay people understood science better
than most scientists
and long-term implications will be
equally profound
so thank you very much and we're looking
forward now to have a discussion uh with
all of you so thank you
[Applause]
thank you Dr koldorf
um
we do have time for a few questions
we have a few students down here in the
front you'll see them holding the
microphones if you have a question
please raise your hand and wait for them
to come to you before asking so that
everyone can hear
thank you very much I'm a retired family
physician and I wasn't the top kid in my
class but I sort of remember when you
got chicken pox you had lifelong
immunity and nobody ever said to me
employer otherwise you've got to get a
chicken box vaccine so I'm going to ask
you a dumb question did science change
two years ago
no
what what he said
I mean I think some vaccines are still
quite important as you know as a family
physician it's just you wouldn't give a
measles vaccine to somebody who's
already had measles and recovered you
don't you if you have when you treat
patients
you treat the patient you're not
treating an aggregate you're treating
the person in front of you and so
vaccine advice should be tailored to the
person in front of you
seems like does not a controversial
thing but apparently in two years the
last two years it has been
we're here
so I'm going to be the contrarian here
tonight I'm just so there was an article
published uh in nature recently about
ssris and how there's no connection
whatsoever between ssris and between
serotonin and depression yet it's a 25
billion dollar industry there's an
article published in science showing
that amyloid beta plaque and
the treatments on that are completely
falsified since 2006
you've got the Sackler family scandal
with oxycodone you've got children's
hospitals that are sexually mutilating
children around the country you've got
medical schools now that are teaching
critical race Theory so my question to
you guys is why why do you want to
restore faith in these public
institutions what makes you think they
deserve it I mean and that last tweet
that you put on that the people that
people understand science better than
the scientists that seems to me to be
correct so I'm just wondering if you
guys could kind of answer that question
for me
I don't think they do deserve trust or
our respect
so
but we have to restore I think the
Integrity of science
and
with our generation of scientists I
don't know if if I'm very hopeful
but the future generation
hopefully can restore
how science should operate
and restore the Integrity of science
and if the intricatory is restored then
I think trust would eventually come back
but I think the key thing is to to
help restore our science and the
scientific Community operates
because now it does not deserve our
trust
you can add something uh very brief it's
not science that's been destroyed
scientists and The credibility of these
scientists particularly those in power
have lost our trust but that's not to
say that science somehow doesn't exist
or factual hypothesis-driven experiments
don't yield good results and I think we
have to be careful
uh to just throw up our hands and say
okay we're not going to listen to
anybody about anything I mean I'm not
sure that's the right answer so I uh and
that's one of the things this is a huge
challenge to to fix it as Martin has
said many times science is broken
uh but it didn't mean that the uh the
whole field should be ignored it means
that we have to we have a lot of work to
do to fix that trust because we must
as a society uh have trust in these
fundamental institutions it's not just
science it's education okay it's it's
Believe It or Not government would be
nice to be able to trust government
uh the media is very critical and has
damaged uh the trust that we need in the
media significantly they are the filter
of information so uh you know yeah I'm
just making the point that uh you know
the challenge is great but uh it's
critical really that we uh in a free
Society with so many different opinions
and people uh restore trust in in
expertise it doesn't mean that we don't
have a burden on ourselves to make sure
we individually know what we're talking
about for ourselves and our families
let me let me add just a second to that
because that's such an important
question
um I I when I was little I loved science
anyone else fall in love with science
when they were little
it's a beautiful thing it is it's an
absolutely amazing way to think about
the world it's a powerful tool to
understand the world and involves a
sense of awe and wonder
um uh that that's worth
building an institution that's
trustworthy to defend it and it just
fills me with sadness to see what's
happened
because what is science why is there
distrust now it's because science has
become a mechanism of power and control
rather than some a a process of learning
about the world that's filled with awe
and wonder uh and so I want I want that
science that I had that vision of
science I had as a child as a kid as a
teenager as frankly still now I want
that to be true I want that I
desperately want that back
um maybe it was never here but I I think
but they could be like it's it's uh it's
it's worth trying for and that's one of
the missions I think of of the Academy
of Science and freedom is to try to
perform science so it's worthy of that
trust worthy it's it's it's it's it has
that Integrity so you you trust it for a
good reason not just because people tell
you to
foreign
I want to thank all of you for being
here tonight and for this talk there's
an interesting juxtaposition as you're
speaking right now president abiden was
addressing the nation and denouncing uh
the extremist Maga Republicans as a
direct threat to democracy and I think
that shows this crisis has Amplified a
very fundamental division in our society
and all of you have addressed tonight
ways to reform science and especially in
public health once science enters the
public sphere then it's political
because science is observations about
the world but when you put a gun to my
head or you threaten my career if you
don't do this
there's an outcome that's not science
that's that's Force that's politics and
so the question I have tonight is
whether or not you believe that
scientific funding from the taxpayer
um can that even continue can we really
have publicly funded science science in
a nation so divided in which you see the
religious aspect uh infect science and
then uh in the sense of liberal piety
you know if you don't believe in
transgenderism there are consequences
Etc so can we have taxpayer-funded
science or is that something that needs
to be on the chopping block
you know there was some
white Dwight Eisenhower uh the president
Dwight Eisenhower when he gave his
farewell address that you remember he
warned against the military-industrial
complex in that same speech he warned
against the rule of scientists go go
back and look at the speech it's really
interesting
um I I don't I don't think that it's
impossible to have a scientific
bureaucracy that funds science even with
federal dollars if if the if controls
are in place but you know like Martin's
vision of of decentralization it's
possible but we have as a polity must
demand it because right now the
scientific viewers we have is is a is a
boot on our neck right so that's I think
with the sense of your your question
it's an open question whether we can or
or can't uh I I want to work toward
making a science and a government that
makes that happen make allows that to
happen it's worthy of trust but we are
very far away from that at this moment
at this moment
I I think that uh Martin uh has outlined
this many times and and very well
tonight which is that the key isn't to
abolish
government-funded research in my view uh
but there's a couple of things that are
very important one in the the message I
think he's trying to focus on here is uh
decentralized oh you cannot have a
monopoly you cannot have a uh uh a
massive domination of science
by any kind of bureaucracy but but by
any single entity that's number one and
number two there's this separation that
we must remember that should exist but
didn't which is the scientific research
funding and the sort of public uh Health
leadership and sort of Medical Science
public leadership which is sort of
different must be distinguished further
this is the wall analogy of Jays
uh and is listed actually as one of the
most important ethical principles of
Public Health
and that is that we need to restore the
role of Public Health agencies and
leaders to advisory they were never
meant to set rules they were never meant
to set laws there was never an intent
for our elected officials to totally
abrogate what they were elected to do
which is lead and to just say
I'll do whatever the CDC says I'll do
whatever the public health people next
to me say that's not part of the
equation that is a gross failure of
leadership and that's a part of the
solution
[Applause]
good evening good evening gentlemen I'm
a pediatrician and a research scientist
I've had to live through a Twilight Zone
of all the rules of how infectious
disease work just didn't apply anymore
for two years but when a child asks me
if something's going to hurt
I always say yes because you don't lie
to patients because that's a crime
against your oath and they'll never
forgive you
which is what's happened on a national
scale
my question is we've had more than
something that shook our civilization
this is an important issue
but there are other things there's
psychology learning science sexuality
climate science all kinds of areas that
are suffering under similar conditions
in the similar problems
what can we do is uh medical
professionals or other types of
scientists what can someone like me do
to participate in the academy and the
discussions
to participate in the framing of this
going forward because that's that's
something that's been sort of a mystery
to me and I was wondering if if you
gentleman could address that
well I mean I can start part of the
structure as you sort of get the feeling
this is a work in progress I want to
make a cafe out there we have already
had a couple of uh events part of this
is sort of
not necessarily the answer but the the
exposure of the problem
and that involves true to a great extent
educating both the general public but
also the the health care Fields I I
don't think most people that I know uh
even in medicine are really either aware
or conversant with what what has
happened because people lead their lives
um individually so we have had a lot of
we have had several public events we are
engaging people all over the country uh
to not just get their input but to sort
of form working groups we have a list of
activities that we're going to do we
have one coming up actually October 21
that has to do with policy on education
and the dissent in science on University
campuses being snuffed out so that
there's a lot of things happening here
that we didn't come forward with but the
part about the general public and
Healthcare Professionals in general is
you know we need your support I mean one
thing is okay I'm just going to say we
need funding to get these things done
but we also want the the Healthcare
Community
to be involved in participating and we
envision as we do events in Washington
DC but also we'll do some things here
and get working groups going that we we
want people engaged in the community to
be on these working groups to formulate
how to proceed with the ideas that
Martin uh you know listed because there
are many about things like the
scientific process articles
communication is very important I think
the medical community okay in my field
feeling was a gross failure okay doctors
were a failure in this and communicating
with their patients and knowing what
they were talking about in stopping the
fear and the pressure and the shame if
people had a different idea of how to
lead their lives so the communication
side is very important and we we want
the community doctors who actually deal
with patients to be involved in these
kinds of discussions so I think there's
going to be a tremendous amount of
possible participation as we roll out
things and as we get things planning and
so just uh you know keep and keep in
touch and keep keep an eye out for what
we're doing I think one important role
of the academy a long-term goal is
public education about how the
how the scientific
system of community has been broken and
how it can be fixed and how it should be
fixed now the three of us cannot do all
of that we need participation of dozens
and hundreds of thousands of people to
do that
and we don't know exactly what the
nature of that is but to have various
Symposium meetings and educational
opportunities and courses
and I think it's important to get this
into sort of
how high school students learn about
about science and how college students
learn about science so that's an
enormous effort I think that will
require a lot of people uh
Educators
faculty at colleges
Physicians
and and so on and and working scientists
in in in different fields who's working
in industry for example so I think
that's a is enormous undertaking
and we don't know how successful we'll
be but I think it's something we have to
try to do and it has if it's gonna if it
ever going to be successful it has to
involve uh thousands of people who sort
of help with these efforts
and I also think at the local community
level a lot of these activities are
going to have spin-offs so that we and
others will be involved actually
directly because things are going to
happen locally nothing's going to happen
good from Washington DC
[Applause]
okay so just one one thing that wasn't
addressed with you said it was so
important science
can't lie
or else it loses credibility doctors
can't lie that is
yeah I mean you have to you have to uh
you have to make a commitment to tell
the truth even when it's really really
really inconvenient
um that's one of I think one of the
ethical principles of Public Health we I
think um the kind of public
participation that Martin and Scott are
talking about that's going to be if it's
just the three of us on the stage we're
gonna fail there's honestly it's just we
are
um but if if uh if we can build a
community of people who who talk to
their patients about things about they
in California there's a law a bill
that's in in on the governor's desk
right now that will uh take away the
licenses of Physicians that dissent
against the ortho or or essentially
Public Health Orthodoxy
actually it's very general yeah so it's
it's not and it's not just covet
essentially those kinds of those kinds
of impositions of power need to have a
vigorous response by the public whose
interests are not served by that
um so I think I want to build a
community
that that that's attuned to this sort of
thing happening pushes back when it
happens it helps
spread the word about how amazing
science can be should be what the
ethical principles are you know how to
how to communicate those that's that we
need just a very large community of you
to to accomplish that
I'm always an optimist I think we can do
it
the way uh you you might want to uh ask
the candidates who are running for
office if they believe in the ethical
principles of Public Health and you can
hand them the piece of paper
so this evening brings into focus a
problem which affects many areas in our
country whether in science
penology parenting education
climate control we are not supposed to
talk we're not supposed to talk and have
a debate therefore
I see a new Golden Rule being created
that encompasses and describes all this
problems never discussed our problems
never resolved
and that's where we are
I mean would you would you do is you're
painting a very Bleak picture of the
current reality of how science actually
works in our lives right a picture of
science English science but various
other areas yeah Society it's political
correctness styming us from having a
discussion
I mean I think I think we felt the three
of us have felt the the sharp pointy
edge of that end of that during the
pandemic like each of us has been
canceled one way or the other through
the pandemic
um I I don't think we can solve all of
society's problems I mean I mean that's
not you know but I think that we can we
can work on the problems we have in
front of us with the the where the where
we have some expertise and some
possibility and some insight
um I think I believe that reform of
society starts from small places and
builds out
uh I think that's how you when when you
have a a pandemic like we've just been
through where the corruption at the
heart of so many systems has been
thoroughly open to the where you can
everyone can see it
um that is an opportunity for reform
nobody wants to live like we live the
last two and a half years not really
not our political enemies not nobody
and so that means that we can build an
enormous Coalition if we could just help
people understand
the vision of what we want which is an
open Society where science plays the
role it's supposed to play where it's
not a boot on your neck but but it's
something to help Empower people
discover new truths uh fill you with a
sense of awe and wonder
um that where the uh the political
authorities aren't using science to get
their way but are Consulting it so that
they can understand what's possible and
then under then then help make and then
make decisions that reflect your values
right that's the society we want to we
want to call for that's the vision we
want I don't see that as a partisan
Vision I think it's possible
I think this is a very attractive way to
think about the world
[Applause]
thank you gentlemen I'm afraid we're out
of time I hope you'll join us out in the
lobby for uh Hospitality uh once again
thank you
[Applause]